my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and beet
regrettin and you love sausages right
yeah what do you enjoy most about
sausages I just love having them with
the baked beans sometimes with baked
beans sometimes these are little button
mushrooms okay you just take them into
that like that look at the hole and cut
them into quarters please now the
important thing about cooking sausages
is they need a bit of color right no
color no things actually get the pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in okay but some mushrooms in
there please motherly now going to watch
your fingers but you know how to slice
onions right now sausages are getting
lots of color cuz this is gonna cook
slowly and it's sort of daddy's version
of the kind of hot pot you know the one
nannies to make for me yes what's about
to come on them and tear them out okay
look no the butter you think into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize so they'll go down by half
give that a little fry okay salt in I
want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that get some
really nice and dark now take your time
in pick off all the little buds that
will get the onions packed with flavor
mmm nice right mushrooms in give them a
nice little stir
did you like to help navi make your hot
spot when she made them for you I used
to always help make the hot pot always
now my mum would never have used this
but aged balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look our
onions look you to caramelize the
vinegars given that nice sort of gloss
put my sausages back in here now from
there some red wine red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is gonna release all that flavor inside
as well look at the color of that now
and it's still not cooked yet
up to the ball really important to boil
it here because it won't ball in the
oven 1:17 in the oven literally 18 to 20
minutes and she goes nice to go with my
hot pot rich golden creamy potato gratin
is a true comfort food classic and I'm
adding a delicious twist beetroot start
by gently heating double cream then peel
and thinly sliced potatoes and cook
beetroot next rub garlic around the edge
of your dish to thoroughly seasoned with
a glorious flavour then grease with a
good layer of butter arrange alternate
layers of potato and beetroot seasoning
in between end with a neat layer of
potatoes and pour the hot cream over the
top bake in a preheated oven for an hour
or until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beet regrettin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish now for
the apple compote what we need to do
first is to get these peeled and sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a taste of that they're
incredibly acidic okay and you need to
cook them those wonderful red apples you
thought I called braeburns what they're
apples you know green ones what they
call em I'm not too sure what the Queen
wants another word for your nun grandma
no no pink lady I know Granny Smith
that's right what we're gonna do is cook
the cooking apples and the eating apples
together I love the combination of the
tartness from the Bramley cooking at all
with the sweetness of the Braben get the
pan nice and hot and sprinkle the bottom
of the pan with caster sugar three or
four nice slices of fresh ginger and
three little cinnamon sticks I want you
to remember that because we're gonna
look for them okay cuz once we've used
them and they've worked their magic I
need to pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving now we just let that go a
little bit darker okay and then replace
it very quick doesn't it give that a
nice little toss okay
cinnamon in ginger in so we're cooking
down the apples butter in gently cook
into the apples soften then take off the
heat
we go into that what's that coming out
down so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show how to do that in a
minute
how many ginger for for ginger and three
cinnamon out with a cinnamon the gingers
I would take a spoon of apples it smell
so nice how nice is that look see the
color apples let's put these in the
fridge to get nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Danny but egg whites are in separate
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle sugar in and then you
turn up a space
[Applause]
oh please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff peaks you lift them up
that is what I call a nice stiff peak
well done next in a separate Bowl whip
double cream until stiff
[Music]
so cream with summers quicker we're
gonna put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream so much better
then sweeten it up with leftover kamilly
compote puree you mix that in nice and
carefully just like this apple
butterscotch now to make the cream even
lighter holding those whisk egg whites
and sugar egg whites into the cream just
nicely fold that in so bring your
glasses back out manage the glasses yep
good girl mmm silly we're off for a
treat open up the piping bag yeah twist
the end they could spoon this in but I
want to just give a nice look it's like
is it a nice captain lemon on top back
in the fridge the beetroot and potato
gratin sausages finished with a flat
leaf parsley now look at those two
beauties mmm it doesn't get any more
comforting than that does it
it's one of the best hot pots ever Tilly
that looks amazing
well done